cũng tới kỳ liệm của trong nắm thành lập đàn.
Một ím chính là 3 môi, 2 ím cũng cho 3 môi, một trong nắm thành lập lực.
Một ím chính là 4, 2 ím cũng cho 4, nắm.
Đạo tháng đặt một tiêu đến nắm 2 ím cũng trong 4, nắm.
Về đám trở thành của gà phát triển không cần thì vừa ngoài phúc.
Nó là các hộ lớn là IG thống nhất của toàn đàn toàn dân và toàn của ta.
Để thực hiện khách phọng đó, ngoài trọng của cô hội trong kính tạo thì tiếp phát triển của ý nghĩa đặc biệt quan trọng.
Không có đột phỏa về thẻ trẻ phóng lật không có một con khỏt mà linh chỉ đoạn,
thành đặc quyền định và chắc kẹp gão thì những một tiêu lớn là位,
có có thể trở thành hiệu tật.
Trong bối cảnh đó, của hội cần tiếp tục phát triển thống 3,5 môi vài bí trước một mức về thẻ trẻ,
giúp cảm quyết định những vừa đề khó, những việc mới những vực chưa có tiền lại,
mở đường cho đổi mối xanh tạo cho phát triển nghen và bình bướt tất liệt.